so when the two brothers had made their
arrangements they set out on their
travels in company with the N voice and
journeyed for a whole year going
northward and northeastward before they
reached the court of that Prince and on
their journey they saw many marvels of
diverse and sundry kinds but of these we
shall say nothing at present because
Massa mark who has likewise seen them
all will give you a full account of them
in the book that follows when the two
brothers got to the great card he
received them with great honor and
hospitality and showed much pleasure at
their visit
asking them a great number of questions
first he asked about the Emperor's how
they maintained their dignity and
administered justice in their dominions
and how they went forth to battle and so
on and then he asked the like questions
about the kings and princes and other
potent aides and then he inquired about
the Pope and the church and about all
that is done at Rome and all the customs
of the Latins
and the two brothers told him the truth
in all its particulars with order and
good sense like sensible men as they
were and this they were able to do as
they knew the Tartar language well when
that prince whose name was Kubla Khan
Lord of the Tartars all over the earth
and of all the kingdoms and provinces
and territories of that quarter of the
world had heard all that the brothers
had to tell him about the ways of the
Latins he was greatly pleased and he
took it into his head that he would send
them on an embassy to the Pope so he
urgently desired them to undertake this
mission along with one of his barons and
they replied that they would gladly
execute all his commands as those of
their sovereign Lord
then the Prince sent to sermon to his
presence one of his barons whose name
was conquered town and desired him to
get ready for it was proposed to send
him to the Pope along with the two
brothers the Baron replied that he would
execute the Lord's commands to the best
of his ability
after this the Prince caused letters
from himself to the Pope to be indicted
in the Tartar tongue and committed them
to the two brothers and to that baron of
his own and charged them with what he
wished them to say to the Pope now the
contents of the letter were to this
purport he begged that the Pope would
send as many as a hundred persons of our
Christian faith intelligent man
acquainted with the seven arts well
qualified to enter this controversy and
able clearly to prove by force of
argument to idolaters and other kinds of
folk that the law of Christ was best and
that all other religions were false and
naught and that if they would prove this
he and all under him would become
Christians and the church's Leachman
finally he charged his own voice to
bring back to him some oil of the lamp
which burns on the Sepulcher of our Lord
at Jerusalem
[Music]
when the Prince had charged them with
all his commission he caused to be given
them a tablet of gold on which was
inscribed that the three ambassadors
should be supplied with everything
needful in all the countries through
which they should pass with horses with
escorts
and in short with whatever they should
require and when they had made all
needful preparations the three
ambassadors took their leave of the
Emperor and set out
[Music]
you
[Music]